the no.1 welcome to this announcement  video from Monday's live show this is a  rather important announcement video  because we have a different starting  time today because of the u.s. time  change I just see a US base so they look  at the US time first and they have to  change to daylight saving time last  weekend so we have a earlier starting  time in Europe so German time it is nine  in the evening nine p.m. central  european time it's still 4 p.m. east  coast time so US has not changed but  European signing time have changed i'm  on one hour earlier please take note of  that everything else is the same but we  just ate start one hour earlier european  time thanks for watching announcer the  hope you will make it on time one hour  before then usual if you are in Europe  thanks for watching